from tiny smart cars to giant SUVs
American factories turn out an
incredible range of automobiles but it's
incredibly rare for one to assemble
what's known as a supercar an exclusive
class of vehicle that's expensive
powerful and ridiculously fast the Acura
NSX is sold by the Japanese automaker
but it is designed and built by a
uniquely American workforce with many
women playing lead roles Don Dahler
reports from outside the Acura design
facility in Torrance California good
morning a supercar is loosely defined by
certain specs it is handmade it can go
from zero to sixty and around three
seconds with a top speed of about 200
miles an hour it's also very expensive a
hundred and fifty thousand dollars or
more and it's rare a u.s. made model
like this NSX may be one of the rarest
of all this was designed here and built
in a factory in Ohio
[Music]
so this is what a cannonball must feel
acceleration that pins your eyeballs to
the back of your skull with a 573
horsepower engine made it to three
electric motors that give the wheels
instantaneous torque the Acura NSX is
made to go fast absurdly and hug every
curve like it's tires were made of
velcro Acura engineer Jason Whitmer is
also a professional driver
it's totally quiet and you think of a
supercar as being loud but this is
completely silent yeah this is a whole
different experience that we brought to
the supercar segment it will sling you
from zero to 60 in 2.9 seconds about the
same amount of time it took me to read
this sentence you have a main gasoline
engine and then you have three electric
motors in this we do the Ennis exes
journey from its beginnings in Japan
almost 30 years ago to being
manufactured exclusively in the US as of
2017 is one of international cooperation
and a company's desire to see if it
could build a car to rival the Ferraris
and MacLaren's and Porsches of the world
if you believe the automotive industry
press they did to find out how we met up
with Acuras vice president and general
manager John Ikeda at their gleaming
Factory in Marysville Ohio this is not
what I picture when I think of a place
where they build cars I mean this feels
more like a hospital it is a super guard
it's a bespoke vehicle is there's so
much technical things in the vehicle so
there is sure that you're not missing
anything it has to be very clean yeah
I'm intrigued by the fact that this
factory is here in Ohio it's not outside
Tokyo so what was the philosophy in
building this car here in the US I think
it's it's the philosophy of build where
you sell and America is the biggest
market for supercars and
we we feel that the people that are here
understand supercars a side benefit to
that good Acura isn't suffering from the
president's tariffs on imported vehicles
but what can the auto industry of
learned from a company that has sold
around 2000 of these models over the
past two years the innovation said we
you know create here anything that we
could do to put it into our regular
manufacturing facilities this is a it's
almost like a study place you know to
try new things to make things better the
NSX is part electric part gasoline it
has state of the art technologies that
Acura and parent company Honda will
eventually use in their less expensive
models they've developed new techniques
rather than painting all the parts
separately like most factories do each
NSX is painted all at once so that the
colors match exactly but it goes deeper
than that
the NSX is built by 100 workers who had
to pass a rigorous selection process
including a written exam they are
literally the best of the best at what
they do the lead designer of the new NSX
was a woman and you see quite a few
building them
Susan dole ik is the weld quality
manager what is it that attracted you to
the auto industry at first really it was
the science I just fell in love with
manufacturing I love the scale of it and
I was just really fascinating this
science this is where brain power meets
horsepower it's undoubtedly a beautiful
car but what makes this a great car I
think what makes this car great is that
it was designed for the driver
completely for the driver we're always
looking at the client what can we do to
put a smile on the face more than
anything else it's not a graph charge
something and how do you graph chart a
smile I don't know but those are things
that the guys are looking for
how do you graph chart a smile just like
this for CBS s morning Saturday Don
Dahler Marysville Ohio alerts our car
Volkswagen bug we drive up to the front
door in that thing that is the crime
factory I've ever seen yeah I like what
you said though during the piece the
idea you kind of want to hear that card
yes yes you do room